lockdown has brought a once in a
lifetime opportunity
to break the chain of hiv transmission
for nick perry who regularly has
tests for hiv getting checked is vital
it's about being in control of my own
destiny
my own sexual health obviously the side
effect of that is i'm also protecting
other people if i know that
that i don't have anything it's peace of
mind really
but it's more than just peace of mind
the sexual health charity terence
higgins
trust says people's sexual habits have
changed during lockdown
and now ramped up testing could break
the chain of hiv
a survey of 800 adults by the trust and
56 dean street found that before
lockdown
42 of people said they would have one
sexual partner a month
and 35 percent would have between two
and five partners a month
but since lockdown 84 percent of people
say they haven't had sex
outside of their immediate household
more than a hundred thousand people in
the uk are currently living with hiv
of these it's estimated that around 7500
are undiagnosed so they don't know
they're hiv positive
it means they're not just living with
bad health but they could without
realizing
spread the virus onto others with
lockdown now easing campaigners are
scaling up postal hiv testing
timing is crucial when you first catch
hiv you have
incredibly high levels of the virus and
you're really infectious to other people
so as so few people have caught
hiv recently there's very few super
infectious people around right now so
that's kind of
adding on to the effect of people having
less sex
and if we can find the people with hiv
and put them on treatment then it
becomes impossible for them to pass
their hiv on the terence higgins trust
is offering free testing kits to groups
most affected by hiv
it's a one-off chance they say to
maximize this unexpected opportunity one
pandemic has had
on another sadia chowdhury sky news